hey everyone no math here I just want to
post two quick announcements for you
first the number of you who have opted
to subscribe to this channel has once
again rolled over a power of 2 which is
just mind-boggling to me I'm still
touched that there are so many of you
who enjoy math like this just for fun
apparently and who have helped to
support the channel by watching it by
sharing some of the content here and of
course for a very special subset of you
directly supporting through patreon
really each and every one of the two to
the nineteenth of you mean a lot to me
and as a thanks and just for fun I'm
gonna be doing a second Q&A session I
left a link to where you can ask an
upvote questions it should be on the
screen here and in the description and
just like with the first one I'll answer
questions in the podcast that I do with
Ben eater and Ben Stein hug since I
don't know I think discussions are more
fun than answers in a vacuum by the way
if you guys don't already know about
eaters channel what are you doing this
man is the bob ross of computer
engineering if you want to understand
how a computer works and I mean really
understand it from the ground up his
channel is 100% the place to go
trust me he is a very good explainer but
anyway the reason I bring him up that he
and I just recorded a pretty interesting
conversation about net neutrality and I
want to be very clear Ben eater is not
against net neutrality and nor am i
however the issue is a lot more nuanced
than I first realized and because there
were already many great videos about net
neutrality and why it's a good thing
which I agree with to offer content that
you may not have seen before
this conversation was a chance to
unearth some of the trade-offs that are
at play here you see the thing about
eater is that before he was creating
phenomenal educational content he worked
for many years in the networking
industry so he has a pretty clear view
of both sides of the equation and a
pretty intelligent way of articulating
what they are I'm just gonna play you a
minute of the conversation here and then
link to the full video if you want to go
see it on Ben's channel which you should
be going to check out anyway but for
those of you who would prefer to listen
to a 45-minute conversation in podcast
form maybe over a commute we did also
publish it as an episode of banben and
have you know consumers kind of want an
unlimited service or we want to believe
we they want to believe you have
concluded service it's essentially
guaranteed that we'll never extra
is that right need and and the you know
the one or two people way off on me on
the end that are that are abusing the
providers are called to be using I think
the customers would say they're you
seeing what they they're paying for but
the ones that are really off the charts
you know the providers like yeah we'll
just limit the traffic will give them
will slow them down or slow down the
applications not to interrupt but
Victorian seems like an interesting
example just because this is a
peer-to-peer type thing and then there's
a whole pile of hype around
decentralized possibilities with like
blockchain and whatnot and to the extent
that that is an aspect of the future of
the Internet that you have a little bit
more possibility for some services to be
a decentralized in this way and I think
there's even a lot of things that just
have a straight-up BitTorrent type
flavor when it comes to file sharing and
things of that sort like do you see that
as a little bit more on the horizon and
would you see that as an example of like
potentially harmful harmful things that
come about when you are very strict
about net neutrality about abiding by it
I would necessarily categorize as a peer
to peer I think the I also I understand
what yeah that you're not saying that
it's like necessarily dangerous to abide
by it strictly I'm sort of eating that
out of you but no yeah I mean I think
the thing the thing that happened with
BitTorrent and we were going a little
bit too far down that rabbit hole but
the thing that happened with BitTorrent
was this was an unusual thing this is
[Music]
[Music]
you